شريكتان برغم بعض الاختلافات الضئيله هكذا
يصف الرئيس الامريكي جوبايدن علاقه بلده
مع فرنسا خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره
الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون اشاركه الابرز بين
البلدين تتعلقوا بالاستمرار في دعم
اوكرانيا
لانهاء هذه الحرب وهي ان ينسحب بوتين من
اوكرانيا لكن يبدو انه لن يفعلها ولذلك
سيدفع ثمنا باهظا لفشله في القيام بذلك
وفي هذه الاثناء اعتقد ان ما قاله ماكرون
بالغوا الاهميه الذي يجب علينا دعم الشعب
لوكرانيين ابدا الى القبول بتسويه
يرفضونها لان ذلك لن يتيح بناء سلام
فالمساله الاساسيه تتعلق بالتعامل مع
الضغوط الاقتصاديه للحرب وخاصه المخاوف
الفرنسيه
بموجب القانون اكيد يخافض التضخم وهو ما
يعتبره الاوروبيون غير عادل لشركات غير
الامريكيه
تتمثلوا رغبه الرئيس جو بايدن في اعاده
تقويه الصناعه هنا
وتامين حلول تكنولوجيه من اجل المستقبل
تريد فرنسا فعل الشيء نفسه ما سيسمح لنا
بايقاف قرابه 15 عاما من التراجع في
التصنيع وخلق حلول صناعيه لبلدنا
وفيما اختتم الرئيس الامريكي حديثه بالقول
ان بلاده لا يمكن ان تتمنى افضل من فرنسا
شريكه لتعمل معها اعتبر الرئيس مقهو ان
مصير فرنسا والولايات المتحده مشتركه
وانهما دوله لشقيقتان في الدفاع عن الحريه